Hey guys,
pilot season continues that wise crack.
This one is another format that's going
to deal with real world issues rather
than focusing on media.
And another reason why we're excited
about this one is this is a continuation
of a collaboration we've had going on
for a while and that is with an artist
named Jr who has been the illustrator
for thug notes since the beginning.
She did all the art for this.
We're super excited to get it out into
the world.
Hope you guys enjoy it.
Let us know.
And on with the show in October of 1992
when the worldwide web was just a few
years old and the idea of streaming
terabytes of pornography was just a far
fetched dream.
A presidential candidate had an
interesting idea.
I will have a unique mandate.
They were going to end the form,
the people in detail on the issues
through an electronic town hall so that
they really know what's going on.
Perot wasn't talking about the Internet
exactly.
He wanted to use technology to
revolutionize democracy.
For instance,
televised town halls or debates could
allow viewers to chime in with their
phones.
Press one for agree to for disagree like
many others,
parole believe new technology could
break down barriers between decision
makers and the average citizen.
Now all these phil is $1,000
suits and alligator shoes running up and
down the halls of Congress that make
policy.
Now,
the lobbyists,
the pack guys,
the foreign lobbyist,
what have heavy,
they'll be over there in the
Smithsonian,
you know,
we're going to get rid of them.
Wasn't
the first to suggest this kind of
electronic democracy and he won't leave
the last.
For those who lamented the corporate
controlled media or the limited flow of
information in authoritarian regimes,
the Internet was a godsend.
One wired article proudly announced that
netizens we're better informed and more
civically engaged in they're unconnected
peers.
By 1997 emir,
8.5%
of the population was considered
connected,
but they voted more,
had greater trust in democracy and we're
more likely to know basic information
like who the chief justice is.
In other words,
these connected citizens were a bastion
of light in the political ecosystem,
but has this light dimmed?
Was it ever there at all?
Sure,
we can now access unprecedented amounts
of information,
but as you've probably guessed,
something is wrong with the Internet.
Let's fast forward to 2010 young people
are doing exactly what futurists
predicted,
connecting on twitter and coming out in
the streets to protest oppressive
regimes in Egypt,
Tunisia,
and elsewhere.
The media heralded the Arab spring as
the first social media revolution,
the promise of the Internet inaction.
Before the Internet,
political organizing was risky.
Business,
stump speeches and flyer distribution
were great ways to end up in jail.
Now,
in the age of tweets heard round the
world,
one can instigate change from the safety
of one's own home until your movement is
too large to quell,
but despite the praise the Internet
earned for his in the Arab spring,
some have argued that the uprisings
proof that the internet can actually
stifle politics.
Why?
Because in Egypt at least the real
revolution didn't start until the
Internet went dark on January 28th,
2011 after several days of widespread
protests,
Egyptian President Hosni Mubarak
shutdown the country's internet like all
of it,
cell phones too in anticipation of what
had been billed as the biggest of all
days of rallies,
the government completely shut down the
Internet in an attempt to stop people
from communicating.
One paper argued that the lack of
internet intensified revolutionary
unrest in three ways.
He angered those who were otherwise
unaware or uninterested in the unrest.
It forced more face to face
communication and it decentralized the
rebellion,
making it even harder to put down.
Similarly,
the Iranian revolution of 1978 and 1979
took place only after a news blackout,
which raises another question.
What if exposure to information doesn't
necessarily compel us to fix injustices
or clamor for a better world,
but just makes us more content with the
status quo?
The author was inspired by another paper
that looked at East Germans living under
communism who had access to Western
media.
I understand our gathering today as
being broadcast as well.
In the east to those listening in East
Berlin a special word.
You might think that seeing a world of
freedom would inspire the East Germans
too to test their oppressive regime and
spur them to rebel,
but it did exactly the opposite.
Eastern Germans with access to western
TV found their life under communism more
tolerable than their peers without it.
TV offered an escape from food lines at
state propaganda.
Why fight for a better world when you
can just watch one?
Why jump over a shark on water skis if
you can just watch the funds do it and
why participate in politics when you can
just retweet someone else's virtue.
In 2014 researchers looked at the saved
are for cause on facebook.
What they found at this point probably
won't surprise you.
The vast majority of caused members
recruited no one else into the cause and
contributed no money to it,
suggesting facebook conjured and
illusion of activism rather than
facilitating the real thing.
To be fair.
There are counter examples like the als
ice bucket challenge,
which raised unprecedented amounts of
money to fight the disease,
but entering a credit card number is a
lot different than being an engaged
citizen where problems are a little more
complicated than dumping money into
research.
And what about our electronic town halls
or the promise that digital citizens
will be more informed than previous
generations.
In 2014 a pew research poll claimed that
thanks to the Internet at least people
felt more informed,
but what should we make of feeling more
informed?
Well,
as early as 1996 mit researchers
prophetically declared that the internet
ran the risk of becoming what they
referred to as a cyber Balkans,
like the countries of the Balkan
peninsula,
which became increasingly fragmented and
hostile toward one another.
The Internet would create insular
realities for its users.
In other words,
they identified echo chambers 20 years
before everyone freaked out about them.
The point is access to information
doesn't necessarily dispel falsehoods.
It can amplify them rather than
discrediting flat earthers,
anti-vaxxers and whatever the hell goop
is.
The Internet has helped them thrive.
And for the rest of us.
Why challenge your own perspectives when
you can find sources that think like you
do.
So what gifts as one philosopher notes,
as we produce more knowledge,
what we gained in Brett,
we lose in depth.
Everyone has an opinion but is never
committed to act on it.
Why?
Because of what he considers to be two
of the worst calamities of the modern
era and an entity and the press.
But this philosopher wasn't talking
about the internet or even the modern
era because he died in 1855 what soren
kierkegaard identified as problems in
the 18 hundreds anonymity,
public opinion and arm chair
intellectual wisdom have been given mega
steroids in the age of the Internet here
regard argued the press invited us to
become detached spectators.
Divorcing thought from action ideas
where homogenized as everyone began to
read the same sources.
Now we read the same and hit like and
share if we agree,
no independent thought needed,
but before getting too cynical,
should we ask,
is this the fault of the Internet itself
or things on it like facebook or
Blowgun?
Paul,
there are tons of examples.
Some studied and some not of the bright
side of the Internet,
times for the Internet helped organize a
community or connect old friends or let
people explore who they really are.
But rather than looking at specific
content,
it's important to understand the modern
internet as a system with a supreme
mandate to produce knowledge,
specifically knowledge about you,
tailored for you and often produced by
you.
The Internet isn't about what kind of
knowledge is produced.
It's concerned with the ever
accelerating exchange of information in
general.
More photos,
more kickstarters,
more video watch time.
It's a system that cares about scale,
not quality,
not integrity.
And despite this ever increasing
exchange of information,
the Internet seems to generate isolation
wherever it goes from early Internet
studies that show users feel more lonely
and depressed on a micro level to the
balkanization of our political landscape
on a macro level.
Whereas Internet evangelists thought
that access to information would connect
people like never before.
It's managed to do exactly the opposite.
But Hey,
at least there's this Bay Bay Bay,
cause I don't know what happened.
Oh No.
Just say it.
Just say,
you love me,
me fall back into speed.
All right,
hope you guys enjoyed that as much as I
did.
A lot of work went into this.
We've been working on it since about
February.
We actually cited 36 different sources
to make the script work,
so you guys can access that research as
well as the research for all of our
videos over@wisecrackplus.com
it's our patrion site.
It's because of our patrons that were
able to do video experiments like this
one.
Most importantly,
let us know what you guys think.
Drop us a comment.
Check out our other pilots,
the one on fake news and the film
tourist.
Let us know what you guys like,
what you don't like.
Your feedback will let us know what we
should continue doing,
so appreciate it guys.
Leave us a comment piece.